[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hear that crowd chanting in the
background well so did camila cabello
and now the singer is clapping back
following her performance at uefa
champions league finale
[Music]
as she sings in the game's opening
ceremony the european soccer fans chant
over her performance
and after watching the footage later
camilla takes to twitter to express her
frustration
she writes quote playing back our
performance and i can't believe people
were singing their team's anthem so loud
camilla adds quote my team and i worked
tirelessly for so long to bring the
right vibes and give a good show
it should be noted some on social media
stressed to the pop star that european
sports famously have passionate fan
bases
as one commenter put it quote many fans
live for their clubs it's their
lifestyle
and this may have led to camila
following up with a more positive
message
she writes quote very rude but whatever
i'm glad you guys loved it
camila's tweets about the ordeal have
since been deleted i think it's all
about being present having fun and not
taking yourself too seriously as hard as
that can be sometimes the performance
comes as camilla proves to be booked and
busy
[Music]
yeah if that tick tock didn't make it
clear camila cabello is officially
taking kelly clarkson's seat on the
voice at least for season 22. i mean i'm
so excited it's camila's first time
taking the iconic red seat
though like kelly she has some practice
when it comes to singing competitions
like getting her start on the x factor
[Music]
and speaking of music
[Music]
camilla is celebrating the release of
her third studio album familia
and while chatting up with e.t at the
met gala camila teases a potential
concert tour
you've got new music out are you going
to be performing up there tonight um i
am not but i am here they were like do
you want to do interviews i was like yes
i got an album out
emilia get that promo
yeah you know i would absolutely love to
tour this album i
love this album and um so let's make it
happen when is it happening i don't know
i don't know but i want it to happen
[Music]
you